let me challenge the way that you think
about it look at this place
currently at Vatican City and look at
just how much incredible art time energy
to human creativity the mind being able
to sculpt and create and paint and make
all of this beautiful art for humans to
just look at thousands of years later
it's mind-blowing and so when you look
at this I want you to think and wonder
to yourself how do people pass time it
took years to sculpt and paint all this
beautiful artwork and think about what
we do today today so often we just jump
right on to Twitter or Facebook or
Instagram and we just mindlessly scroll
through that we don't actually unleash
our full creative potential into the
world so this is a challenge for us to
figure out how to parse those social
networks fir the most signal and cut out
the noise and also unlock our creativity
and bring that into the world and focus
more on that on making view
things like this and also things of
great utility to maximize human
flourishing let's get there together
everyone let's figure it out look at
this bring us back in time much love
everyone